if president trump is looking ahead at
the future and saying
okay look i want to win this i feel we
did win this i feel there was a lot of
fraud i feel there was a lot of cheating
but guess what buddy if you guys do
manage to win this at the level of the
courts
you're not going to keep me down i'm
going to keep running again that's the
right attitude some conservatives
are getting demoralized including some
of the most
vocal defenders of president trump sean
hannity on his
program the other day was speaking with
the lawyer sydney powell
and sean hannity suggested that if biden
becomes president
if donald trump is on his way out that
he should issue a pardon
for himself and for his family
i watched andrew weissman come out and
literally say oh
biden's a.g needs to go after donald
trump
and i'm like the president out the door
needs to pardon his whole family and
himself because that they want this
witch hunt to go on in perpetuity
they're so full of rage and insanity
against the president i mean it's
can the president i i assume that the
power of the pardon
uh is absolute and that he should be
able to pardon anybody that he wants to
it is absolute it's in the constitution
i don't know about his authority to
pardon himself
but it should not be necessary and aside
from that the president's going to get
another four years in
office to finish the job he started so
sydney powell is still
really holding out hope we'll get in one
second to her
legal strategy here you'll recall that
sydney powell is not working
officially with the trump legal campaign
while the trump campaign
is focusing on specific uh matters of
election fraud and unconstitutionality
in pennsylvania
sydney powell is pursuing this idea that
there was a national
very widespread uh hacking scheme
to shift votes so she's still pursuing
that but
to sean hannity's point seems to me
that's not the right attitude to have
due respect to sean
i get it it's true the biden legal team
is going to
try to go after trump they're going to
have a lot of
encouragement from the base to these
frothing jackals of the
democratic base to to go after trump
once he leaves office
but i don't think trump should pardon
himself because trump hasn't done
anything
illegal there would be nothing to pardon
himself for
and you know i think that's sort of
hannity's point he says whatever they go
after trump for he should just pardon
himself now i don't think that's how
pardons work
we certainly haven't seen that sort of
thing in american history
i think if trump were to do anything of
that sort it would be
giving in too much it would be giving
into despair and discouragement
it would be giving into fear servile
fear by saying
i think they're going to come get me so
i exonerate myself of what i don't know
but whatever they accused me of i didn't
do it
and it would be in a way an admission of
guilt
guilt again for what i'm not quite so
sure
in america we do not have a political
tradition of
jailing our vanquished politicians at
least at the presidential level
and we don't have a tradition of jailing
our political opponents in this country
even though some of them probably do
deserve jail uh
for instance some people who were the
former future or first female president
four years ago
you know those sort of people there is
evidence that they've done things that
are illegal we still don't put them in
prison
because that's what tin pot
dictatorships do that's what banana
republics do and we don't want to do
that
if president trump were to pardon
himself as
sean is describing here it would be
a sort of concession that we're now
living in the world where we jail our
political opponents once they leave the
presidency
i don't think that's the right way to
play it i understand
why people are reacting with such
extremes to this legal process right now
either to saying the whole country is
completely over or to saying
that trump's got to give up immediately
or the country's over it's because we
don't like
tension i've noticed women especially
don't like tension they don't like
apprehension
but generally we all don't like
uncertainty and so we want to resolve
the uncertainty
even if it resolves in a way that is
unpleasant even if it resolves in a way
that would that we're fearing
even if it resolves to the point that
we're now saying we jail our political
opponents once they leave the presidency
but they just because we don't like the
apprehension we just want some
conclusion
so we don't need to be in suspense life
is lived in suspense
you don't know what's going to happen
patience is a virtue and
if you if you keep up that sort of
attitude where you say okay you're going
to do your worst to me
you're going to completely vanquish me
you think you've vanquished me i don't
think so i'll see you in four years
that is a winning strategy that is
courage now
you heard sydney powell on that clip
mention that
she is convinced that there is this
nationwide election fraud
and not just that there's nationwide
election fraud but that they will prove
this in court
and president trump will get another
four years in office which
she's describing a sort of confidence
here that i think even
president trump is not necessarily
displaying so what
is her evidence the election fraud we
are uncovering
is massive and there were foreign actors
involved in
our system uh people from germany and
serbia
and china were all in our election
the night it happened so i have no doubt
that foreign actors tried to interfere
in the election
i'm not sure exactly how they did it
this was by the way our response
in 2016. the left said that the russians
tried to interfere in the
presidential election and some
conservatives i guess deny that but i
don't deny that the russians tried to
interfere
foreign actors try to interfere in every
single election the question is how
successful were they with the the
so-called russiagate
they bought a hundred thousand dollars
worth of facebook ads media companies
spend that in a week on facebook ads
that that doesn't that's nothing that's
not gonna affect it
now cindy powell's claim is that these
foreign actors were actually going and
hacking the voting system shifting the
votes
again i have no doubt that they would do
it if they could i have no doubt
that they are that corrupt and they want
to
to mess up our system the question is
can you prove it and time is ticking you
know we have what
less than 10 days now until no about i
guess about 10 days until
the electors vote so how much longer
before we
how much longer do we have to wait how
much longer we have to be in the
suspense and apprehension
to see this evidence of the hacking it's
not enough
to say i have a hunch that this happened
sure
it's not enough to say this could have
happened absolutely it could have
happened
you have to prove it with certain that's
just a descriptive
fact of our political and judicial
system you've got to prove it
with a high degree of persuasion and so
far we haven't seen that happen
so i hope that she brings the goods but
as of now we haven't seen it now there
is specific evidence of fraud
in in certain cases not even just at the
presidential level
in one congressional race in new york
involving a congressional candidate i
actually know personally
the two candidates the democratic
incumbent and the republican challenger
are separated by 12 votes
i want to talk about your vote mattering
want to talk about going out there even
if it's a system that's
vulnerable to fraud so new york's 22nd
congressional district you've got the
republican claudia tenney
has a 12-vote lead over the democratic
incumbent anthony brindsey and
that's good news right because that
means claudia's going to win the
republicans going to win we're all good
it's been it's been almost a month now
since
the elections i think we should be able
to count our ballots by now
talk about a tin pot dictatorship we
can't even count our ballots within a
month
well no we have to keep counting the
ballots until the democrat wins
claudia has a 12 vote lead well guess
what conveniently
they just found a batch of 55 ballots
they were hidden i don't know where they
were they were underneath the mail truck
or something
they just found this batch the uh
chenango county attorney alan gordon
said that election officials
determined that of these 55 ballots
found 44 of them are valid now
the other way to read that is 11 of
these votes
were fraudulent were ineligible
how'd they end up there so 44 are valid
44 could
swing an election easily if the election
is
right now hanging by 12 votes
so uh this county attorney
has advised the board of elections to
secure the ballots leave them unopened
in their offices
and obviously throw out the ones that
are illegitimate
but now 44 ballots i hope they're
unopened i hope that
their legitimate ballots i hope that
they weren't just being held
in case they were needed by the
democrats but when the votes trickle in
and trickle in and trickle in
until the democrats win that that does
not give us confidence in the system
it it discourages us in some way because
we feel like we can't win but they're
still fighting claudia tenney
is still fighting and there's a lot of
uncertainty right now
of course but do we want to just throw
up our hands or do we want to actually
try to secure
our future